[missile firing]
[machine gun firing]
[missile exploding]
David Marquet: What?
Crazy.
I'm David Marquet,
former nuclear submarine commander,
and I'm gonna watch some submarine clips,
and we're gonna rate them for realism.
Officer: Torpedo!
The Americans are shooting at us again.
Jonesy: Pitch is too high.
The torpedo's Russian.
[torpedo firing]
David: Yes, you can tell
what kind of torpedo it is
by the sound that it makes,
and all different torpedoes
have slightly different sounds.
So, one of the things we do is study
all those different sounds to help us out.
Officer: Conn, sonar,
new contact, Sierra 4-1.
Alfa-class Soviet submarine.
David: Alfa-class Soviet submarine.
It sends shivers up my spine!
The Alfa was this crazy submarine
that the Russians built back in the '70s.
People were trying all
kinds of different things.
They had a titanium hull.
They used liquefied lead
to cool the reactor,
if you can imagine such a thing.
It was the fastest,
deepest-diving submarine ever.
Basically it's like a Miyata
with a Corvette engine.
It was a crazy submarine.
Officer: Weapon enabled on
the far side of the target.
It passed Red October before it armed.
David: If you turn your
torpedo on too far out there
because you're trying to
get as close as possible
and you overshoot, you missed.
Ramius: Melekhin, more speed.
Melekhin: Negative.
You're already running 110%.
Ramius: Then give me 115%.
David: No, you don't do 115% on a reactor.
You do 100%. Point zero. [laughs]
Officer: They didn't shoot at us.
I can't attack a Soviet
submarine without authorization.
David: That's right.
Rules of self-defense
don't let you do that.
You see how Sean Connery
and Scott Glenn, playing the
two submarine commanders,
they're, like, cool as cucumbers.
These guys are within a few seconds
of maybe getting blown to bits.
This is exactly the way
submarine commanders are.
Mancuso: You're heading
straight into that torpedo.
[torpedo firing]
David: It's a highly unlikely maneuver
to actually work, especially twice.
And the torpedoes would
never be that close together,
so that, it loses some credibility.
But overall, the sense of
not really knowing what's going on,
the sense of having to make decisions,
the sense of this cat and
mouse is all really good.
When I joined the submarine force,
I didn't come from a military family.
My mom's like, "What do you do?"
And I'm like, when this movie came out,
I'm like, "Mom, watch this
movie! This'll tell you."
Eight out of 10.
[tense music]
[man screams]
[glass breaks]
We don't use glass on
a submarine like that.
[laughs] And that's why.
[submarine crashing]
Considering these guys
just drove into the bottom,
they're in pretty good shape.
Unfortunately, we kind of
know what this looks like
because in 2005,
a US nuclear submarine did hit the bottom.
This was a glancing blow.
98 of the 135 people on board
suffered some sort of injury.
It was very bloody on the submarine.
A lot of contusions, broken bones.
And this would be much worse than that,
because it went straight down.
They were going straight into the bottom.
And so I think letting
everyone sort of be OK,
yeah, we saw some people bumping around,
but basically everyone was OK afterwards.
Of course you can't have
a movie if everyone dies.
That's the end of the movie.
The sense of what it's like
when you turn vertical, though,
that's pretty good.
So I'm gonna give it a six out of 10.
You don't want to do this, by
the way, on your submarine.
[explosion]
[man screams]
Why that torpedo just fell
over kind of that easy,
it looked like there was a cable cut.
These things are strapped
down in multiple straps.
It's really hard to dislodge them.
And then the other thing is,
what they're showing
here is pretty accurate.
It takes a lot for the weapon to go off,
and the thing falls and bounces;
the weapon's not gonna go off.
You hit it with a hammer; the
weapon's not gonna go off.
You heat it up; the
These things are designed so that
it takes a very specific
sequence of operations
to make the actual warhead go off.
So, these are torpedoes,
with the classic propeller on the back,
and they're designed to go
sink other ships or submarines.
Submarines also can carry
missiles that can attack
land targets and missiles
that can attack other ships,
and also mines that would
lie in wait for the bad guy.
It only takes one of
these modern torpedoes
to sink all but the very largest warships.
It's a space that every crew member
on the submarine would have access to
and would be knowledgeable about.
The reason is because if
there's some sort of a casualty,
we need to muster the
entire crew to go find it.
The philosophy on a submarine
is, "One crew, one fight."
So with very few exceptions,
the entire crew has
access to the entire ship.
I'm gonna give it a seven out of 10.
[menacing music]
[submarine explodes]
Barney: Mayday! Mayday! The
engine room has sprung a leak!
David: Now, this scene from "The Simpsons"
sends shivers up my spine,
because this is the worst fear
of all submariners, flooding.
At deep depth, the water
comes in very, very quickly,
and you don't need to
flood the entire submarine.
Here's what happens.
Let's say there's water in the
front part of the submarine.
That part of the submarine
starts to get heavier,
and then the submarine
starts to tip down like this,
which means that the
water in the submarine
rushes more towards the front,
and it makes it even heavier
and tips down even more.
And so what happens is now the sub,
you end up like this.
And when you're like this,
your ballast tanks don't work anymore.
You can't use the air
to blow the water out,
because the air will just go out the side.
This is how you die in a submarine.
And if you saw the movie "Titanic,"
that's how that ship sank.
And you remember at the end of the movie
as the ship was sinking,
the Titanic was rising up,
and that's because the water was cascading
from compartment to
compartment to compartment.
It's called the free-surface effect,
and that's how you die on a submarine.
It's not pretty.
Now, if you're taking on
water like these guys are,
the first thing you're going to want to do
is come as shallow as possible.
That does two things for you.
No. 1, the pumps that
are pumping off the water
have less pressure to pump against,
so you're pumping off faster
and the water coming in has
less pressure behind it.
Easiest way to stop
flooding on a submarine,
because most of the
water inside a submarine
is coming in through pipes,
is we have these valves
that we can shut. Isolate the system.
Now, here, it looks
like it's next to a tank
or maybe even the hull. In that case,
it's a very, very difficult problem,
because when you get a leak,
that water is spraying in so hard.
It's harder than any water
cannon you have ever seen.
And they show it here; it's trickling in
like a limp garden hose!
There's no way!
So, you're pushing against the pressure
to put an earring pin in there? No.
The most realistic thing
in this whole scene
is the guy underwater drinking beer.
So I gotta give them, like, at least
a three, though, for trying. [laughs]
Morozov: From here to here.
Robinson: Which means we are
on one of these two ridges,
or we'd be crushed.
David: Yeah, now, these
charts are very accurate.
You can see they have contour lines,
and for a body of water
like the Black Sea,
which humans have operated
in for a long time,
it's probably very well mapped.
That's probably accurate.
Robinson: No, the Black Sea
is anoxic at depth. No oxygen.
David: Yeah, the Black Sea is
a very special body of water.
It's basically like a bathtub,
and it has very little interaction,
and you have rivers flowing into it,
and then that flows out
to the Mediterranean.
So, deep, there's a layer
where the deeper water is anoxic.
There's very, very little oxygen.
And as a result, there's little decay.
Now, I'm not sure it's
perfectly preserved,
but it's just like finding
human remains in bogs.
They're very well preserved.
Whether they can use
the driveshaft or not,
I don't know.
But it's still overall
nine out of 10 for realism.
That's true.
Ramsey: We have rules that are
not open to interpretation,
personal intuition, gut feelings,
hairs on the back of your neck.
Hunter: Captain.
Ramsey: We're all very well
aware of what our orders are
and what those orders mean.
David: This is exactly right.
You wanna side with Denzel,
but what Gene Hackman is saying
right here is exactly right.
These guys are trained on this 100 times,
including the exact kinds of errors
that they're seeing right now.
But then he takes it too far.
Ramsey: Cob, arrest this
man and get him out of here!
Hunter: Capt. Ramsey,
under operating procedures
governing the release of nuclear weapons,
we cannot launch our missiles
unless both you and I agree.
David: That's right.
So, Denzel doesn't need
to get in a big argument,
he just needs to say, "I'm
not gonna announce that."
The rest of the crew knows.
The procedure is if they
don't hear both voices,
those missiles aren't gonna fly.
Gene Hackman doesn't have
the right to remove him
from his position because
he doesn't agree with him.
It's set up so that two people
independently have to make the decision
to launch nuclear weapons.
It's such a huge deal.
Ramsey: I order you to place the XO
under arrest under charges of mutiny!
David: Now, this is all just a fantasy
that some Hollywood people dreamed up.
First of all, it's not mutiny,
because Denzel is not
collaborating with anybody.
It's just, he's by himself.
Mutiny would mean he has a whole bunch of,
or at least one other person with him.
Denzel can't relieve the captain
just because he doesn't agree
with the captain's decision.
Commanding officers can get relieved
for, for example, a medical reason,
he's incapacitated.
Having a disagreement about something
is not a legitimate reason
for relieving your commanding officer.
No one would follow that order.
I'm gonna give it, like, a
four out of 10.
[alarm ringing]
So, that's kind of what
it would look like.
Now, the reason they have to practice this
is because a World War II submarine
spends a lot of time on the surface.
It's really more of a submersible,
because they have diesel
engines and they need oxygen.
Nuclear submarines,
we spend almost all of
our time underwater.
So, let's say you're on the
surface, steaming along,
and all of a sudden someone sees
an airplane coming toward you.
You gotta get underwater
very, very, very quickly.
So what's happening is
the people on the bridge
are coming down from the bridge.
Now, the hatch is open,
but at the same time
we're opening the vents
and flooding the submarine
and tipping it deep.
You gotta get the hatch shut
before the water level
comes up to that level,
or all of a sudden you're
gonna start taking flooding.
So it's a very highly choreographed
and synchronized event.
This is a 10 out of 10.
This is exactly what it
would have been like.
Man: Chief of the watch,
submerge the ship to 160 feet.
David: So, you see here,
the submarine spends
as little time on the surface as possible.
Submariners are allergic to sunlight.
The whole point of being a
submarine is to stay underwater.
So they pop up at the very last minute,
and as soon as they get
the SEAL team on board,
which they do very rapidly,
shut the hatch and
submerge the ship again.
Here's the thing in war.
If you can be seen, you can be targeted.
If you can be targeted, you can be shot.
If you can be shot, you can be killed.
So the best way to break
that chain of events
is at the very beginning.
Overall, I'm gonna rate this
a seven out of 10 for realism.
Vostrikov: The reactor repair has failed.
At any moment we could have an explosion,
which could set off the warheads.
David: No. Reactors don't explode.
This unfortunately is perpetuating a myth
that we have to fight in nuclear power,
which is that reactors are
somehow like nuclear weapons
and that a reactor's gonna explode
like nuclear weapons can.
So, first of all, the
reactor's not gonna explode.
Secondly, I'd say within their power,
it might melt down, but
it's not gonna explode.
If it exploded, the chance of it igniting,
detonating secondary weapons, zero.
'Cause the other weapons
are designed not to go off
just because there's
another explosion nearby.
Vostrikov: This would
destroy the American ship
only a few kilometers
from the NATO base.
David: It wouldn't set off the warheads,
'cause the warheads are
designed not to detonate
unless their detonation
sequence goes through.
You can't, if you blow up a warhead,
it doesn't also blow up.
The chance that they'd be so close
that if their warheads went off,
it would destroy this other
ship or the NATO base,
again, highly, highly, highly improbable.
Vostrikov: We could dive and
attempt to repair the reactor.
David: No.
What does diving have to do
with repairing the reactor?
You just repair the
reactor wherever you are.
So, I mean, they don't really
have much of a choice here.
Either they don't try and fix the reactor
and risk an explosion, or
they try and fix the reactor.
So it's not like there's
a whole debate here,
but I'm gonna rate this a zero out of 10,
because not only is it
totally unrealistic,
but it perpetuates
some of the unhelpful
myths about nuclear power.
Klough: This is the Navy,
where a commanding officer's
a mighty and terrible thing.
Don't you dare say what you said
to the boys back there
again, "I don't know."
David: Yeah, this is a
command philosophy thing.
Now, I'll tell you, I like
to say, "I don't know,"
because what it does is it
invites thinking from the crew.
When Capt. Sullenberger
landed his airplane,
the Airbus on the Hudson River,
one of the last things that
he said to the copilot was,
"Hey, you got any ideas?"
What you want is everyone
on board and thinking.
Now, maybe in an extreme
crisis you don't wanna act
like you don't really
know what's going on,
but 99.999% of the time,
saying, "I don't know,"
saying, "What do you think?"
That's really a good thing.
Klough: You're the skipper now.
And the skipper always knows what to do,
whether he does or not.
David: The official title for
the captain of a submarine
is commanding officer or
CO or sometimes captain.
That's a very common thing.
But here, Harvey Keitel
refers to Matthew
McConaughey as "skipper."
That comes from an old German Dutch word
that's based on ships: schip, schipper.
Another term for the captain
is little less fun.
It's called the "old man."
And they might refer to
the captain as the old man
'cause typically the captain
was the oldest person on the ship.
Now, you'll notice they're
wearing different uniforms.
And the idea, it comes
from back in World War II,
the submarines, because they're so tight
and so claustrophobic,
they were a little less
formal than the surface ships.
And the men tended to take some liberties
with their uniforms.
This is pushing it a little bit.
On modern submarines,
what you're gonna find
is everyone is looking very professional.
We have common uniforms,
and they're designed
to protect us from fires
and things like that.
So we take these uniforms very seriously,
because they could end
up saving our lives.
I'm gonna give it an eight out of 10.
Man: Captain, we're
prepared to counter launch.
David: Yeah, so this
is the first question.
"We're prepared to counter launch."
Counter launch what?
Submarines don't have weapons
to shoot down other missiles.
They have weapons to shoot down
ships and other submarines.
[missile firing]
[guns firing]
[missile exploding]
What?
Yeah, that's an incredible
weapon, but not that incredible.
Look, these missiles are the size
of small school buses.
They're flying at 1,000 miles an hour,
they're this far away, coming
this way at the submarine,
you put 100 bullets in
that thing in two seconds,
it's still gonna go right
through the submarine.
Crazy.
Multiple issues with tactics.
The physics of the
thing don't really work.
I don't think any submarine
commander would act that way.
I love the movie, but it's not realistic.
I'm gonna give it a three out of 10.
[singing and drumming]
Yeah, I don't think so.
Here's the problem. Sound
does not transmit well
between a big interface,
like the water to the air.
So, you can stick your head underwater
and you can hear, say you
could hear whales and stuff,
then you put your head in the air;
you don't hear them anymore.
And the reverse is true.
Sound that's in the air doesn't
transmit into the water.
If he were drumming on
the side of the ship,
the side of that little rowboat,
and that rowboat was transmitting
the noise into the water,
then, yeah, I could hear that,
but it wouldn't have the fidelity
that these guys are listening to.
Good movie, but this
scene, not so realistic.
Five out of 10 for this particular scene.
Murrell: Mr. Ware, set
depth charges to 100.
Mr. Ware: Arr!
[death charges firing]
David: Yeah, so in World War II,
none of these weapons were guided.
You had to drive directly
over the enemy submarine
and launch your depth charges,
hopefully setting them to the right depth.
[sonar beeping]
Von Stolberg: He's turning.
David: So, he's listening to the sonar,
and when you have two propellers,
those destroyers have two propellers,
and so when a ship starts to turn,
what happens is the water
pressure is different
and so the two propellers
get a little out of sync.
So instead of going,
[mimics propeller noise]
it's like, [mimics
out-of-sync propeller noise]
and you can hear that.
And that's what the
submarine captain there
is listening to.
So, the destroyer went over,
and now it wants to come
back, but it has to turn,
and at that point, it's very broad.
That's the point of maximum vulnerability.
I'm gonna give this an eight out of 10
for what World War II
submarine-vs-destroyer combat looked like.
There's no way! So, you're
pushing against the pressure
to put an earring pin in there? No.
The most realistic thing
in this whole scene
is the guy underwater drinking beer.